Gutfeld presents another Vegas story
what the hell just happened and whatever
it was what the hell was that
yeah he flaunted his junk putting
gamblers in a funk a 35 year old tourist
aren't they all was arrested after
bizarre nude Escapade at Harrah's casino
on Sunday TMZ giving me the video No
Doubt doing God's work you see Brian I
don't know his name I can't pronounce it
so moving on strolling along but things
took a turn for the worse when he hopped
on a table roll it
and that was the roulette table
but who knows if his ball landed on red
or black
yeah
but here's where it really gets good
[Applause]
[Music]
that is disgusting I didn't even see
that
wow that makes this joke
a little bit more troubling
but trust me it's nothing I haven't seen
in The Fox and Friends Green Room
but security finally showed up and got
him under control Brian's family told
the New York Post his behavior was
completely out of character someone had
spiked his drink with a hallucinogenic
drug at a bachelor party earlier that
night which explains his altered state
of mind apparently he doesn't remember a
thing that happened his wife is 33 weeks
pregnant says they're good people and
her husband's a great person and he
would never act in such a way and that
he's the victim they just bought a home
together
Brian a computer program was still
busted for disorderly conduct and five
counts of indecent exposure he was also
slapped with a battery charge for
allegedly slugging slugging a one-legged
man
probably for putting his remaining foot
down
but the question remains why would a
normal male decide to ruin his life
is it obviously a case of being drugged
we go to our experienced expert on the
unique effects of illicit substances
not me no
[Music]
Kaylee I I'm so interested interested in
this story because I think that like we
hear people getting drugged and turning
into something that they're not his
friends say that he was claiming that he
was feeling unusual except after having
a drink what do you believe do you
believe that this is just like a a a
crime that happened to him not a crime
he committed well first I believe I've
been defamed as a sports bettor and a
drug connoisseur so take it back
um I've thought deeply about this story
uh it is very peculiar and apparently he
said he was just sitting around talking
about homeowners insurance right and
then someone comes to him with a drink
and it was a pretty innocuous drink
seemingly and then 10 to 15 minutes
later he gets paranoid runs out and does
this yes I'm sorry something doesn't add
up I'm just glad it wasn't it's Long
Island man and not Florida man so I
don't have to claim this individual yes
you know I'd like to give a shout out to
our blur that's good blurring I had a
very busy week
blurring a lot of things imagine what
dense nightmares are like cat being the
blur the things that they see they can't
talk about the problems they bring home
to their family I don't want to talk
about it and his wife is blurred
look at me for once she yells you can't
see anything okay
the expert here she didn't give an
answer
that guy's dancing can you be spiked
with an illicit substance and still
dance like that that's what I'm
wondering
I think it's the only explanation for
dancing like that yeah yeah like that's
the alcohol is like oh we got too drunk
he seems to be possessed by something
I'm completely on his side because
regardless of any dispute about whether
he was drugged or not there's no dispute
that that's absolutely what you should
say yeah
these are smart people these are smart
people these are good people and his
wife that this is relationship goals yes
she's she's pregnant she's not mad at
all she's like it is horrible what
someone did to my husband
anyone who's just mad about this is mad
they don't have that kind of
relationship at home I mean screw all
these like YouTubers or like look at our
happy relationship no this right here is
the relationship we should all strive to
have absolutely this baby is the
luckiest baby in the world
I take a completely different tact on
this when you go to Vegas all the
casinos look the same this one was
Harrods I think they're all the same now
how do you differentiate yourself you
get performance artists Ah that's what
he is and now if I knew I could see that
guy perform every night let's say eight
o'clock you can at my place
I'm telling you
yeah you know there's no reason for him
to get arrested that is a performance
that's what it is it's eclectic it's art
and it's at this particular Casino every
night at eight o'clock they'll get
thousands more people streaming in there
that's marketing that's that's marketing
that's it and you would invest in that
kind of I'm going to invest right now
who is this guy Casino slash exhibition
you know Lee do you have a law degree I
do ah I knew you were a lawyer okay have
you ever heard of the Gutfeld theory of
insane exoneration that if you commit a
crime you do it with such absurdity that
the only excuse could be Insanity so if
I were to mug you which you'd probably
beat me up but let's say you're asleep
and I mug you but then I would draw all
over you and then I would spend all the
money on like Furbies
then he would go oh he's got Guilty by
insanity is this guy like is he insane
should what would you do if you were
defending him well first off there was a
whole block on this on studying for the
bar exam your theory and uh I I feel
like I'm a an expert but not as much of
an expert as you I would say that there
has to be some level of uh I don't know
if insanity is the right word but I
believe the theory that there was
something in his system making him him
act like this I love how the saying has
withstood the test of time by the way
you know what happens in Vegas ends up
on Gutfeld yeah
appropriate
though people underestimate the effects
of like substances I always go back to
that guy on the plane in Canada it was
Connecticut and he ended up defecating
on the drink cart oh God and he was an
MD he was a nice guy and he definitely
but he had like some kind of pill and he
went up in it and lost his mind I think
we all should just say a prayer for
people who defecate on drink cards yikes
I don't know why I brought that up
a problem I know you can't help yourself
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else